[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous présente
le club des territoires
et avec nous dans ce club pierre
Jacquemin bonjour Pierre bonjour
merci d'être là journaliste politique
aux échos on va parler entre autres avec
vous du 49-3 déclencher cette nuit par
Elizabeth borne sur la loi de
programmation des finances publiques le
premier texte de la session le
gouvernement est-il dans une impasse
politique vous nous direz ce que vous en
pensez Mathias on va parler avec vous de
la pré sénatoriale et oui des élections
des présidents de groupes et puis les
rapports de force entre les différentes
formations politiques ici mais d'abord
on va voir l'actualité dans nos régions
on va encore
l'actualité dans nos régions du côté de
la Corse Emmanuel Macron est arrivé hier
soir pour entamer une visite de trois
jours et pour en parler on va à Ajaccio
retrouver Henri Mariani bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous directeur
délégué de Corse-Matin leur Aurore hier
c'était donc la première étape de sa
visite Emmanuel Macron est arrivé tard
dans la soirée à Ajaccio première étape
un dîner républicain à la préfecture
oui effectivement un dîner autour des
principaux élus Gilles siméone et le
président du conseil exécutif de Corse
plusieurs élus de sa majorité mais
également des parlementaires des maires
pour esquisser et commencer à esquisser
ce que pourrait être son discours vous
savez que chef de l'État vient à
l'occasion des des 80e anniversaire de
la libération de la Corse le premier
département libéré mais pas que il va à
l'Assemblée de Corse ce matin à 10h
prononcé un discours politique un
discours très attendu par par les élus
ce discours c'est un peu de la part du
chef de l'État les pilogues de 18 mois
de discussion entre entre la Corse et
Paris entre entre les élu corses ceux de
la majorité mais également les mers les
parlementaires les sénateurs et le
gouvernement représentait un carnet
pendant cette période de dialogue par le
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin
et puis il y a eu début juillet ce vote
de l'Assemblée de Corse majoritaire 43
43 voies 46 voix pardon sur 63 le texte
en faveur de l'autonomie de Lille
proposée par par la majorité autonomiste
de Gilles Simeoni et le président de la
République ce matin lors de son
allocution l'Assemblée de Corse brossera
que pourrait être selon lui en tout cas
sa vision de de l'évolution
institutionnelle de la Corse dans les
prochains mois et qu'est-ce qui va se
passer ensuite alors Henri
et bien alors ensuite il y aura
évidemment le long cheminement
institutionnel le long débat
parlementaire le gouvernement va donc
proposer très probablement un projet de
loi qui sera débattu à l'Assemblée
nationale au Sénat puis en congrès et là
les difficultés ça m'ont celles déjà
Emmanuel Macron et le gouvernement n'ont
pas de majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
les résultats des sénatoriales vous en
parliez dans votre édition de 8 heures
on conforté la majorité du Sénat LR dans
nos colonnes lundi lundi dernier dans
les colonnes de Corse-Matin Bruno
Retailleau le patron des sénateurs LR au
Sénat a déjà mis un certain nombre de
préalable à ce que pourrait être
l'évolution institutionnelle de la Corse
et évidemment ça ne va pas dans le sens
du projet qui est porté par Gilles
Simeoni par les autonomistes donc le
chemin est encore long il
semer d'embûches très probablement et
l'issue est bien évidemment les chutes
politiques est encore incertaine
aujourd'hui à l'heure nous parlons et
très probablement pour les pour les
prochains mois encore et tout ça
évidemment ce sera à suivre avec vous en
rien à lire dans Corse-Matin regarde la
une du jour parole au Président c'est à
la Une de votre journal et vous allez
suivre ces deux jours encore de
déplacement du chef de l'État dans l'île
on suivra bien sûr tout ça avec vous
merci Henri Marianne d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin un mot pierre avec vous
puisque Emmanuel Macron qui devrait
faire des annonces hier il aurait
employé le mode autonomie lors du dîner
avec les élus est-ce que on parle
beaucoup de décentralisation Emmanuel
Macron lui-même parle beaucoup de
décentralisation depuis le début de son
premier quinquennat est-ce qu'à un
moment il doit donner des gages aux élus
en tout cas il doit les écouter et c'est
bien qu'il fasse le déplacement je pense
que les corps sont vus
aperçus entendus un certain nombre
d'acteurs de premier plan la première
Premier ministre avec qui elle est en
relation avec les locaux le ministre de
l'Intérieur évidemment mais j'ai le
sentiment quand même que Emmanuel Macron
et ça va avoir avec le sujet qu'on va
aborder après c'est à dire qu'il est
aussi pied des points liés avec
l'existence de du Parlement et il a pas
de majorité de nulle part donc il a beau
dire et avancer des termes comme ceux de
l'autonomie il a pas les marges de
manœuvre pour pouvoir
promettre en tout cas au corps et
notamment aux autonomistes des avancées
notables et rapides c'est pour ça que le
journaliste avait raison l'autre
confrère de Corse avait raison de
rappeler que tout ça va va être un long
long chemin mais déjà de la part
d'Emmanuel Macron essayer de d'engager
une discussion avec les îles locaux
c'est déjà un bel effort qu'il faut
souligner
c'est un vieux problème la Corse et puis
il y a une énorme attente dans l'île la
plupart des Corses ça fait 20 ans les
grands-parents les parents se battent
pour une forme par l'indépendance mais
au moins une forme d'autonomie de Lille
donc c'est il y a une forte attente
est-ce qu'il arrivera à y répondre
de toute façon l'assemblée corps c'est
déjà assez remonté
nationalisme mais au moins des
indépendantistes donc oui ça pose
plusieurs autonomistes tout à fait donc
est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron arrivera à
apporter une réponse à la fois mesurer
acceptable par les deux parties ce matin
Bruno Retailleau dans le Figaro expliqué
qu'il n'était pas question d'aller vers
un statut de statuts c'est-à-dire un
site de citoyen à part à la fois Corse à
la fois française il y a la
reconnaissance de la langue officielle
aussi pour un double statut donc ça pose
plein de questions même d'un point de
vue républicain sur nos institutions et
la manière dont on soit citoyenneté
est-ce qu'il arrivera à apporter une
réponse à la fois acceptable des deux
parties avoir à suivre évidemment
puisqu'on suivra ce déplacement du chef
de l'étape pendant deux jours sur l'île
on va parler du Parlement et notamment
ce qui s'est passé hier dans la nuit il
était presque minuit hier soir quand
Elisabeth borne est monté à la tribune
de l'Assemblée nationale pour déclencher
le 49,3 sur le premier texte de la
session Jérôme Rabier
les débats n'auront pas duré longtemps
pour étudier à l'Assemblée nationale la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques qui fixent la trajectoire
financière du pays jusqu'en 2027 entamé
à 21h30 la séance a été interrompu peu
avant minuit la première ministre venant
couper court en engageant la
responsabilité du gouvernement nous
avons
besoin de nos finances publiques nous ne
pouvons pas prendre le moindre risque le
12e 49 3 d'Elizabeth borne n'a surpris
personne les textes budgétaires n'étant
pas propices au compromis à gauche la
nuque unie sur cette question déplore
les mauvaises habitudes du gouvernement
on a un gouvernement qui est 49-3
dépendants totalement addict aux
violences faites au Parlement la
première ministre donc la saison des
49-3 autoritaires nous la nuit pèse de
notre côté ouvrons notre saison de la
censure populaire une motion censure que
le rassemblement national réfléchit
également à déposer faute d'avoir obtenu
du gouvernement les compromis demandés
côté majorité relative on dénonce une
coalition des opposants qui ne fait pas
avancer le pays il y a les oppositions
ne sont pas capables d'être raisonnables
d'être responsable et de dépasser des
clivages
traditionnels là où l'émotion de censure
on peut de chance d'être adopté une
partie des républicains refusant de se
lier des autres oppositions sur la
question le texte devrait donc être
adopté fixant la trajectoire financière
du pays jusqu'en 2027 mon pierre c'est
quand même tout sauf une surprise c'est
49-3 bah oui c'est évidemment pas une
surprise et surtout on est écoutant les
différents interlocuteurs se succédaient
on a le sentiment que c'est une histoire
qui se répète et qui va se répéter
jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat mais le
seul qui a les règles du jeu entre les
mains en tout cas qui peut changer les
règles du jeu c'est Emmanuel Macron on
peut pas gouverner enfin il est
impossible de penser qu'on va gouverner
à coup de 49-3 en permanence surtout
quand il s'agit de projeter la France à
une échéance aussi lointaine qui est
celle de 2027 on peut pas parler de
planification écologique et dire qu'on
va faire 70 milliards d'économies sur
une échéance à 3-4-5 ans c'est pas
crédible donc du coup quand je dis
qu'Emmanuel Macron elle est
à la main sur les règles du jeu c'est
que il y a beaucoup de quand même de
projets d'ambition qui sont portés par
le Président de la République je disais
la question écologique et la question
sociale évidemment aussi sur la question
du coût de la vie de manière générale on
peut pas avancer en sans essayer de
trouver des promis avec ces
parlementaires Emmanuel Macron on a rien
à faire des parlementaires on voit
comment il règle la question de la
démocratie sociale on voit comment il
arrive la question de la démocratie
parlementaire par le 49-3 il doit
trouver les voies dans le compromis et à
mon avis le seul compromis possible
c'est pas en désalliance à droite à
gauche puisque il n'y arrive pas y
compris sur le sujet comme solde
migration et certainement pas sur les
sujets comme ceux de l'économie ou ceux
du budget mais sans doute en passant par
une par un vote parce que je crois que
la seule chose qui peut aujourd'hui
changer la donne et peut-être permettre
aux uns aux autres de dégager des
majorités et donc de nouveaux gouverner
sur la base d'un régime parlementaire
oui je vois pas d'autres solutions que
la dissolution Jacques est-ce que là
Elisabeth borne avait d'autres choix non
après pour un petit bémol sur ce que dit
Pierre il y a quand même une engagement
du gouvernement sur une sur un 49-3 donc
il engage sa responsabilité voir
impossible 49-3 a priori ce sera pas
adopté parce que la républicains ont pas
l'intention de faire sauter entre
guillemets l'assemblée ce qui est
important c'est de rappeler aussi ce qui
a été dit par Bruno Le Maire et Thomas
casin c'est Cazeneuve c'est-à-dire que
il y a des fonds européens qui étaient
prêts à débloquer
on voit de programmation de finances
publiques plus réelle on n'a pas les
fonds nécessaires pour engager justement
la transition énergétique donc les deux
arguments valent à la fois il faut
débloquer un budget pour pouvoir
financer la transition et d'autres et
d'autres d'autres postes de dépenses et
en même temps il y a un enjeu de je suis
d'accord avec vous démocratique
d'adhésion à la politique budgétaire de
la nation elle l'a fait parce que alors
il y avait une subtilité parlementaire
dans cette histoire qui a été beaucoup
répétée depuis hier soir c'est que ce
texte intervient dans une session
extraordinaire ce qui permet l'usage
d'un 49-3 c'était jusqu'à je crois ce
soir ou hier soir donc on était ric-rac
pour pouvoir l'activer est-ce que
ensuite ce texte pourra pour suivre sa
vie parlementaire en revenant au Sénat
et continuer à bénéficier d'un 49-3
qu'il protège c'est toute une question
juridique et constitutionnelle qui va
être posée plus tard en tout cas les
oppositions ont l'air déterminé à faire
valoir ce point et sujets intéressants
les LR surtout qu'il y avait il y a eu
un faux suspense à un moment hier enfin
avant-hier pour savoir si LR allait au
moins s'abstenir comme le RN le professé
ils ont décidé de voter contre parce
qu'ils veulent s'en créer dès le début
de la fin dès le début de l'année dans
une opposition au Parlement
Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'ils vont jouer
le jeu jusqu'au bout là ils l'ont ils
n'ont pas ils vont pas censurer le
gouvernement a priori donc il y a des
voies de passage moi je pense que c'est
une question d'assumer le 49-3 a priori
elle le fait il y en aura plusieurs il y
en aura d'autres 11 depuis le début de
la session parlementaire la dernière
fois donc il y a pas de problème
institutionnel oui parce que comme
Jacques le dit Pierre et langage la
responsabilité de son gouvernement
est-ce que c'est pas aussi la preuve que
les oppositions sont incapables de le
faire tomber ce gouvernement il y a pas
de majorité alternative c'est ce que
répète la majorité présidentielle on a
eu la visite du roi et de la reine la
semaine dernière on a on a commenté la
visite donc d'un roi dans le système
monarchique et et et leur système est
plus démocratique que l'autre on a à ce
moment-là évidemment rappelé que
Emmanuel Macron était le monarque
présidentiel et je ne cesse de penser
qu'on a précisément un problème
démocratique institutionnel de notre
pays là j'entends effectivement les uns
et les autres de la majorité de dire
c'est l'irresponsabilité des oppositions
non les oppositions elles ont un cahier
des feuilles de route qui éclaire ils
ont des propositions ils ont été devant
les électeurs avec une ligne qui était
la leur et on peut pas leur on peut pas
leur reprocher de mener l'opposition
dans notre démocratie de faire tomber le
gouvernement en revanche vous avez
raison oui mais en revanche l'opposition
quand elle dépose sa mousson censure
c'est pour ça qu'il disait c'est tout ça
est un théâtre parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'on peut on peut dire
jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat quels
seront les propos de la France insoumise
et ce de la majorité présidentielle mais
mais tant qu'il y a pas une décision
comme une dissolution ou alors
l'acceptation aussi d'un certain nombre
de compromis ce que je disais tout à
l'heure par le gouvernement en reprenant
des propositions de de loi reprenant des
amendements qui sont déposés par la
France insoumise ou le Parti socialiste
et écologistes ou les républicains ce
que je veux dire c'est que on le voit
bien de de session parlementaire on voit
bien que le gouvernement de reprend
quasiment aucune des propositions des
avancées des amendements qui sont
déposés par les parlementaires de
l'opposition donc on peut reprocher aux
oppositions de pas faire leur travail ou
d'être désirs responsables une
opposition elle est là pour se poser et
essayer de de nouer des compromis avec
le gouvernement ce qui ne veut pas
il y a un problème aussi c'est que la
majorité est pris en étau à la fois
entre une opposition de gauche qui a des
propositions plus radicales et un RN qui
se fait constructive soudain donc ils
ont une difficulté à la fois à faire
exister leur flanc droit et leur flanc
avec LR qui leur permettrait d'échapper
à la tenaille entre RN et extrême gauche
c'est très compliqué d'où l'usage du
49-3 après là vous avez raison sur la
dissolution ça permettrait de régler un
problème démocratique le problème c'est
qu'est-ce qui sortirait des urnes si on
sort avec un RN renforcé c'est encore
plus un gouvernable que précédemment ça
veut dire quoi un premier ministre à
l'air qui permet de réorienter la
majorité encore plus à droite pour
flotter des textes avec le RN voilà la
situation devient un peu un peu étrange
donc je c'est un compromis entre des
oppositions qui n'ont pas envie pour
l'instant d'appuyer sur la gâchette le
RN va proposer peut-être une motion de
censure ce qui était plus ou moins la
surprise parce qu'il voulait s'abstenir
sur ce texte donc ils ont quand même un
double langage en permanence il s'adapte
ils sont assez forts dans la matière
parlementaire il y aura sur la suite du
budget et la discussion budgétaire
probablement une émotion de censure du
RN la question ça reste encore une fois
LR est-ce que LR décide de faire sauter
Isabelle bornes moi je pense pas
je suis d'accord avec vous on a le
sentiment que que les LR jouent leur
notabilité c'est à dire que
ils sont pas fait partie qui a envie de
mettre en difficulté un gouvernement
limitant difficulté de nos institutions
alors que précisément je pense que comme
il serait justement au centre du jeu et
les presque les arbitres d'une décision
absolument vitale fondamentale dans dans
l'époque politique que l'on vit il
pourrait avoir ce courage de le faire et
de prendre cette décision qui remettrai
des cartes après évidemment tout ça
c'est de la théorie parce qu'on sait
très bien que derrière les républicains
dans le cas d'une élection législative
risque de perdre des plumes on l'a vu au
Sénat ça fait d'entre eux même s'il
reste majoritaire ils ont quand même
perdu un salon un certain nombre de
sénateur donc la famille des
républicains a elle-même beaucoup à
faire et à s'interroger sur sur sa
philosophie sur sa colonne vertébrale
politique et qui me paraît totalement
compatible avec Emmanuel Macron donc
tout ça pour moi est un véritable jeu de
dupe vous faites la transition pierre
puisque on va parler derrière c'est na
dimanche amélior on rappelle les
sénatoriales elles n'ont pas bouleversé
les grands équilibres la majorité de la
droite et du centre est sorti confortée
mais si on regarde dans le détail à
l'illustre quand même le fait de cette
élection que la poutre travaille encore
comme le disait Édouard Philippe alors
avant d'en parler avec vous on va faire
le point sur ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières heures au Sénat Mathias les
groupes politiques sont en train d'être
formés ils ont jusqu'à mardi mais
sénateur pour se rattacher mais en tout
cas certains groupes politiques ont déjà
élu leur président c'est ça ils sont
réelles surprises Oriane Bruno
Retailleau et reconduit à la tête du
groupe les républicains et pour cause et
bien le sénateur vendéen n'avait pas de
concurrent officiel même s'il se murmure
que quelques sénateurs auraient vu d'un
bon œil qu'un autre candidat tiens
pourquoi pas Alain joliandais sénateur
de au-dessus de Haute-Saône pardon se
présente ne serait-ce que pour la forme
alors un Bruno Retailleau reconduit à la
tête du premier groupe au Sénat mais qui
devrait perdre précaution il faut
attendre encore la semaine prochaine
pour avoir les chiffres définitifs mais
entre 9 et 10 sénateurs et non pas 3 ou
4 comme il l'évoquait sur le sur notre
chaîne dimanche soir
notre famille politique elle est pas
obligée de sa forme
2020 c'était très particulier parce que
le phénomène Renaissance il n'y avait
pas je veux dire un enracinement et non
plus horizon quand vous avez des
départements des grands agglomérations
comme Reims comment manger qui partent
sur horizon vous avez une conséquence
arithmétique moi je suis désolé le
groupe LR va rester de très très loin le
premier groupe et c'est d'ailleurs parce
que nous sommes le premier groupe que le
président susanna est issu de ce groupe
et des républicains qui ont la compris
vont donc faire quelques plumes et qui
voit également le rallier historique
l'Union centrée se renforçait quelque
peu plus trois ou quatre sénateurs pour
le groupe d'Hervé Marseille lui aussi
réélu haut la main à la tête de son
groupe et donc forcément des rapports de
force qui pourraient évoluer entre les
deux composantes de la majorité
sénatoriale avec entre 57 et 60
sénateurs dans les projections les plus
optimistes l'Union centriste est loin
derrière les 135 attendus chez les LR et
pourtant bien ce groupe est sera faiseur
de roi et pourra donc peser encore plus
dans les débats comme sur la loi
immigration ou encore sur le projet de
loi de finances on va parler de la
gauche en quelques instants mais sur la
droite la majorité sénatoriale Jacques
alors elle est renforcée en tout cas
elle est confortée de ces élections
sénatoriales mais on le voit dans le
détail est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à un
léger rééquilibrage au sein de cette
majorité ils ont toujours Hervé
Marseille et Bruno Retailleau le groupe
LR Union centriste sont toujours
travaillé de concert il y a jamais eu de
dissension très très marquée en tout cas
sur sur le texte immigration va
peut-être voir les premiers les premiers
frottements sur ce sujet notamment il y
a l'article 3 qui concerne les métiers
en tension l'Union centriste est plus
pour passer par un sujet de règlement en
fait pour revenir à l'esprit du
règlement et c'est les préfets qui
s'occuperaient ce qui était la position
initiale du gouvernement ensuite LR on a
fait un casus Belly une ligne rouge
comme isamel répéter et alors la
question ensuite de l'Assemblée est-ce
que les députés vont suivre le Sénat qui
aura trouvé un accord éventuellement
avec les centriste enfin tout ça est en
recomposition moi ce que je note et ce
qui me paraît le plus signifiant dans le
résultat ce scrutin c'est que les
tickets l'étiquette LR c'est mousse elle
est elle est de moins en moins
privilégiée par les par les grands
électeurs c'est même principalement des
conseillers municipaux donc elle est à
un certain nombre de villes qui lui
permettent quand même de maintenir sa
force politique mais on voit quand même
qu'il y a des tentates c'est de la
moitié des villes de moins de 9000
habitants tout à fait tout à fait
exactement mais on voit qu'il y a un
attrait des autres groupes qui
permettent d'exister de concerts plus ou
moins avec la majorité de temps en temps
en tout cas le gouvernement le groupe de
Claude malure augmente ses effectifs
c'est lui qui le rappelait au soir de
l'élection quasiment 30%. c'était un
petit groupe assez minimaliste donc ça
se voit tout de suite beaucoup plus vite
c'est le groupe juste les groupes les
indépendants avec des sénateurs horizons
je pense à voter avec LR si il y a des
accords avec la majorité trouver mais ça
ça montre qu'il y a un petit émoussement
en tout cas de de la force politique de
LR dans le paysage politique est-ce que
je pense que l'unité sera préservée
Bruno notariaux la répété maintes et
maintes fois c'est la condition
sinequanone de la bonne santé
l'institution et du Sénat Hervé Massey
qui a un républicain devrait pas avoir
des velléités autres mais ça ça en tout
cas ça renforce aussi le rôle de
l'actuel majorité et le gouvernement va
forcément essayer de jouer sur ces deux
tableaux
encore une fois je le répète mais sur
l'immigration il y aura une vraie
discussion au Sénat parce que le texte
arrive en novembre sur le point
essentiel de l'immigration oui
ouh là les LR et les centrices pour le
coup ne sont pas d'accord est-ce que
quand même il faut s'attendre à quelques
fissures au sein de cette majorité de
sénatoriale pierre d'abord je voudrais
saluer le travail des équipes de public
Synaps parce que j'ai regardé j'ai suivi
ces sénatorielles qui n'intéressaient
visiblement aucune autre chaîne
d'information puisque il y avait peu de
traitement de l'actualité sénatoriale ce
jour-là et donc j'y suis avec attention
et vous allez faire un travail
remarquable
ensuite sur la sur les sur les sur les
conséquences politiques de tout cela
vous avez raison sans doute il y a des
fissures on sait tous que aujourd'hui ce
qu'il se joue c'est la majorité
présidentielle de 2027 donc chacun
revoit un peu ces la configuration et
les périmètres de ces accords avec ceux
avec lesquels ils pensent que
une majorité pourrait être dégagée en
2027 après manuel Macron tout le monde
est dans l'après Emmanuel Macron et
c'est ce qui s'est passé aussi au soir
du du de ces élections sénatoriales je
disais qu'il y avait très peu d'intérêt
sur ces élections alors que précisément
sans doute la recomposition de la droite
je se joue pour partie au Sénat on voit
bien dans les débats qu'il y a eu dans
le
[Musique]
donc sera ce sera un scrutin à fort
potentiel politique est-ce qu'à ce
moment-là le début de recomposition
qu'on est en train de voir sera
complètement achevée et qu'on aura un
début de de d'après Macron ça c'est une
question qui va vraiment se poser et on
est au prémices de ce de ce mouvement là
ça peut déjà commencer à se jouer on
sait que dans le groupe centrisme
notamment il y a déjà des gens qui ont
envie d'aller regarder du côté
d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'on peut
aussi envisager en début d'alliance
entre Édouard Philippe et Gérard Larcher
dans les dans les faits non après il y a
un candidat officiel de LR j'aime
toujours le rappeler qui s'appelle
Laurent Wauquiez après si Laurent
Wauquiez et en dessous de 10% ça risque
d'être un peu plus compliqué et devoir
Philippe aura beaucoup plus de charme
de présenter un candidat ou c'est encore
trop tôt pour le français en tout cas
c'est ce qu'il a réexauty le président
des LR la juré mordicus mais mais c'est
un secret de polichinelle que la poutre
comme vous le disiez très bien travaillé
encore on a beaucoup de sénateurs il
suffit de d'interroger quelques
sénateurs et l'air qui vous expliquent
que les positions de d'Édouard Philippe
et téléler il y a très longtemps
finalement c'est pas Édouard Philippe
qui a changé et qui est revenu à la
maison donc non non c'est ça va la
poudre va beaucoup beaucoup travaillé
deux ans c'est assez court finalement
[Musique]
voilà
à mon avis il se joue deux de choix en
fait pour les pour les républicains et
c'est d'ailleurs la question à laquelle
il n'arrive pas véritablement à répondre
même s'ils ont répondu en choisissant
Erik sotti mais je pense que ça fâche
aussi une partie des sénateurs c'est à
dire est-ce que les républicains
redeviennent un parti de droite
républicaine sociale à la Chirac un peu
sans être trop d'extrême droite sur des
sujets régaliens la police la question
migratoire où est-ce qu'au contraire ils
vont grignoter du terrain sur le côté de
Marine Le Pen moi ma conviction c'est
que jamais c'est comme la gauche quand
la gauche avait sur le terrain l'extrême
droite et jamais récupérable les voies
de l'extrême droite maladroite quand tu
as fait la même chose c'est pas en
allant sur le terrain de l'extrême
droite qu'elle récupère les voiles
d'extrême droite donc je pense que c'est
véritablement en route en retrouvant une
espèce de centralité
démocratique en tout cas républicaine en
reprenant le terrain que le créneau qui
était celui d'Emmanuel qui a été celui
d'Emmanuel Macron même ce qui nous a
vendu en même temps mais pour moi il a
toujours été président de droite c'est
en reprenant ce terrain là d'une droite
sociale et donc peut-être effectivement
celle de de d'Édouard Philippe que les
républicains peuvent se surtout que le
Sénat a un nouveau rôle qui est crucial
les textes vont commencer à arriver
enfin c'est la plupart des textes sont
proposés d'abord ce qui était autrefois
des textes plutôt de ratification entre
guillemets maintenant c'est des vrais
sujets de discussion donc le immigration
qui arrive d'abord donc le Sénat
retrouva recrutial et après faut voir si
Bruno Retailleau Hervé Marseille seront
assez intelligents je pense qu'ils ont
l'habitude pour faire valoir les points
précis vous avez parfaitement raison la
vraie question c'est qu'est-ce qui va se
passer finalement l'assemblée on a un
groupe qui est ultra minoritaire mais
qui sera peut-être en contradiction même
avec ses propres sénateurs ça pose plein
de questions à suivre on va voir ce qui
se passe à gauche parce que c'est aussi
passé des choses à gauche au Sénat cette
semaine parce que dans le premier groupe
d'opposition sénatorielle c'est-à-dire
le PS il y a eu des dissensions il y a
eu un remake du congrès de Marseille au
foyer Clémenceau à quelques mètres d'ici
Oriane dans le rôle de Nicolas mayor
Rossignol on retrouve Patrick canner
président sortant du groupe PS au Palais
du Luxembourg c'est la ligne frileuse à
la newpaisse on va dire et dans le rôle
d'Olivier Faure et bien c'est le
sénateur des Landes Eric kerouche la
ligne plutôt pro-up le vainqueur vous
l'avez c'est Patrick Kammer
il reconduit avec 38 voix contre 25%
challenger pas une victoire écrasante
mais le président réélu assure tous les
socialistes travailleront ensemble
qui est rouge était candidat c'est qu'il
a souhaité porté il a dit lui-même une
autre voie avait eu lieu et Vox du
groupe donc c'est tout à fait normal mon
premier message c'est le dit ça a été de
dire tu as présenté un programme j'ai
présenté un programme regardons ce qui
est compatible si qui va fonctionner
ensemble et nous porterons cette feuille
de route non pas au nom de Patrick kaner
ou non d'Héric et rouge mais au nom d'un
groupe socialiste rassemblé alors les
grands équilibres ne devraient pas
changer on l'a déjà dit mais on peut
quand même s'attendre à quelques
batailles et la première d'entre elles
vous l'avez déjà évoqué c'est la loi
immigration je pense que ce sera un bon
test pour voir les appuis des uns et des
autres et les alliances et les accords
partisans ouais on va dire un mot de ce
qui s'est passé à gauche parce que c'est
quand même assez significatif ce qui
s'est passé au sein du groupe socialiste
est-ce que quand même il faut y voir une
défaite de la ligne produite pierre
non je crois pas parce que le Sénat
c'est pas non plus une chambre
révolutionnaire on n'aime pas beaucoup
les grands changements
ce que je pense c'est que il y a une
forme de il y a une volonté chez les
sénateurs socialistes d'assumer une
forme de continuité patricaner et pour 6
ans sans doute dans trois ans il passera
la main à une nouvelle génération enfin
j'imagine que c'est un peu ça qui s'est
joué aussi au sein de c'est un dans un
contexte compliqué politiquement ou
effectivement il y a des débats à gauche
assurer une forme de continuité en la
personne de Patrick Kanner personnalité
un peu consensuelle ou en tout cas qui
est pas très clivant tout ça de son
groupe même si c'est pas non plus la
notoriété incarnée mais il a en phrasé
apaisant il est je pense pour le groupe
quelque chose quelqu'un qui sur lequel
on peut s'appuyer y compris avec ceux
qui ont été ses opposants comme ericaush
donc je vois pas une grande lecture très
politique de c'est la victoire des
antinèdes des antinupestres contre
contre ceux de la nupes je
il y a plein il y a plein d'autres
conclusions à tirer je pense que c'est
sénatorial notamment sur l'ensemble de
la j'ai notamment le fait que la gauche
on sort un tout petit peu plus renforcé
parce que rassemblé elle aurait été
encore plus renforcée si elle avait été
rassemblé jusqu'au bout avec la France
insoumise je pense c'est une des leçons
je vous invite à lire le guide de Michel
souder dans politicien de semaine où il
fait le décompte justement dans les dans
les sénateurs dans les dans les
circonscriptions où il a manqué quelques
voix un certain nombre de sénateurs qui
aurait pu être des écologistes des
communistes et là où la France insoumise
avait obtenu plusieurs dizaines de voix
donc du coup s'il y avait eu la France
insoumise c'est clair mathématiquement
arithmatiquement il y avait peut-être
une dizaine d'autres sénateurs élus à
gauche alors que la France que la France
insoumise c'est aussi un repoussoir dans
les territoires et que avec la France
insoumise ils auraient eu mon délu si
l'accord avait concerné un sénateur je
pense pas que ça aurait repoussé
beaucoup de monde est-ce que ça montre
quand même ce qui s'est passé lors de
ces sénatoriales à gauche Jacques une
fracturation de la nuque ça montre que
effectivement le Sénat est réputé plus
sage donc ça montre qu'il y a une une
constance au moins à travers l'élection
de Patrick canin ce qui avait été dit
pour la candidature de son O
c'est que il voulait une meilleure
articulation entre le groupe PS à
l'Assemblée et à les sénateurs donc
Boris Vallot enfin si Maurice et ça
montre un bureau pour la santé voilà
tout à fait donc ça montre qu'il y avait
aussi un besoin de travailler de concert
pour faire porter des arguments et c'est
le problème originel de la nuit et on le
voit à l'Assemblée elle est fracturée
sur des sujets
même qui que les plupart des Français
sur lesquels la plupart des Français
n'ont pas d'avisent chicane la plupart
du temps donc il y a il y a un besoin
d'unité qui a été qui a été qui a été
présenté pendant ces élections la France
insoumise a été entre guillemets un peu
exclu du scrutin elle aura pas voix au
chapitre
ce qui est faisable au Sénat ce qui est
possible au Sénat est-il possible à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est de moins en
moins sûr moi ce que je retiens de cette
de ce scrutin c'est aussi que le la
bonne performance des Verts qui ce qui
est un peu à contre-courant de ce qui se
passe à l'Assemblée et même d'un point
de vue électorale aux élections
présidentielles ils ont fait une bonne
une bonne une des bonnes municipales la
dernière fois ça se traduit aujourd'hui
à travers plusieurs élus grand élus qui
permettent d'avoir des sénateurs
écologistes dont la benjamine de
l'Assemblée nationale 29 ans il fait
baisser chuter la moyenne de façon
drastique et donc ça ça montre que les
équilibres Sénat sont plutôt c'est une
évidence que de le dire mais sont plutôt
le reflet de ce qui se passe dans le
territoire que le produit d'un débat
politique souvent compliqué difficile
qui qu'on le voit régulièrement la
semaine nationale mais est-ce que ça
montre pas contrairement à ce que dit la
France insoumise que la gauche peut
gagner sans eux
la France insoumise on peut pas la
gauche ne peut pas prétendre de vouloir
gagner des élections et reprendre le
pouvoir sans la principale formation
politique de gauche la France insoumise
au niveau national la France insoumise
je dis pas écrase parce que constater
quand la machine est en route que
Mélenchon fait une bonne campagne
ça devient le vote ça a été le vote
utile une partie des socialistes une
grande partie des socialistes ont voté
Jean-Luc Mélenchon donc ça me paraît
compliqué de d'imaginer que la gauche
peut reprendre un jour le pouvoir en
excluant
la principale locomotive à noter quand
même aussi c'est ça qui est intéressant
je trouve c'est dans ces élections ces
deux personnalités de gauche contre
haut-parleur au Sénat c'est Yann Brossat
l'élu communiste de Paris et il y a une
jaloux je trouve que pour l'image du
Sénat aussi ça ça renforce cette idée
que le ça n'est plus qu'une chambre
où on étudie les lois on les voit etc
depuis quelques temps il se passe
quelque chose de Sénat aussi et je pense
que c'est intéressant et le fait que le
scénario redevienne être actif pour un
certain nombre de personnalités comme
Yannick Jadot même si on sait très bien
qu'il y a une cadeau où Yann brossa et
William Brossard aussi des ambitions
derrière tout ça mais je trouve que
c'est plutôt intéressant et c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle pour la gauche et
pour le Sénat oui ça laisse présager des
compositions intéressantes des
commissions mixes paritaires qui doivent
trancher sur des textes qui sont réputés
un peu conflictuel plus on a de délu
socialistes plus on a des lus
écologistes plus on a des ulr plus ça
permet le débat aussi et de trouver des
accords et du consensus qui est paraît
aujourd'hui impossible aux yeux des
Français qui se désintéressent vraiment
de la vie au Parlement la gauche avait
réussi à se faire entendre dans ce
nouveau Sénat pierre
j'entends beaucoup
le commentateur ou même de d'élus
l'expliquer que la gauche elle est morte
que de toute façon laupes ne survivra
pas regarder le Sénat de toute façon il
a fait un choix ce qu'on disait à
l'instant anti-ups j'ai quand même le
sentiment que la gauche est condamnée à
s'entendre et pour qu'elle s'entende et
pour qu'elle soit Audi y compris au
Sénat il faut un moment donné qu'elle
ait des espaces où il y a des
discussions ça va maintenant on vient de
passer les sénatoriales il va y avoir
les municipales il va sans doute y avoir
de nouvelles enfin les européennes avant
ce qui fait un autre sujet pour la
gauche mais je crois que oui la gauche
va être Audi parce que d'abord je me
l'avait rappelé il y a plus de sénateurs
les communistes gagnent deux sénateurs
les écologistes on gagne je crois 4 et
les socialistes sont encore à ce stade à
peu près équilibré par rapport à la
précédente au président Parlement donc
je pense que oui ils vont s'entendre la
gauche c'est naturel s'entend mais en
général ils arrivent à se mettre
d'accord sur un certain nombre de sujets
et donc c'est fait entendre c'est un peu
plus compliqué sur les retraites c'était
plus compliqué bon ils étaient quand
même tous les deux tous les groupes
étaient opposés au ils sont pas d'accord
sur le projet ils sont pas d'accord sur
l'alternative pas d'accord sur la
stratégie qui était celle des de la
gauche à l'Assemblée nationale mais ils
sont au moins d'accord pour mettre mal
le projet de réforme enfin la réforme
c'est moi qui a adopté de des retraites
et globalement la gauche et naturelle
s'entend quand même sur quand même pas
mal de suite donc elle sera se faire
entendre la question c'est notamment
avec l'arrivée des deux personnalités de
Yannick Jaden grossesse qu'elles se
feront entendre davantage
que l'on fait c'est leur prédécesseurs
on suivra tout ça on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler on regarde ce qu'il y
avait une de nos quotidiens régionaux
avant de se quitter
[Musique]
et Mathias sont donc cette revue de
presse avec la visite d'Emmanuel Macron
en Corse
la fin d'un suspense et les
qualificatifs ne manquent pas à la Une
du journal Corse qui attribue à présent
la parole au président Emmanuel Macron
qui s'est fait discret hier lors de son
arrivée tardive à Ajaccio et qui doit
prendre la parole ce jeudi matin devant
l'assemblée de Lille autonomie ou pas le
chef de l'État est également attendu sur
des sujets comme la langue la terre et
les volets politiques et l'économiques
la Charente Libre mais elle a une les
pompistes indépendants ceux qui auront
le plus de mal à mettre en place le prix
coûtant au risque de la panne sèche
exemple avec un couple de gérant d'une
supérette qui assure ne peut ne faire
qu'entre 5 et 6 centimes de marge par
litre sur lesquels il faut prendre le
dépannage des pompes électricité et qui
par conséquent ne pourra pas pratiquer
le prix coûtant un constat inquiétant
pour les représentants du secteur qui
craignent que les plus faibles mettent
la clé sous la porte alors que le texte
immigration est en négociation les
métiers en tension prennent et c'est
Midi Libre qui ce jeudi donne la parole
à des patrons à la peine restauration
aide à la personne BTP les témoignages
se multiplient dans les pages du journal
Montpellier on y trouve par exemple le
cas d'Anissa une Marocaine sans papiers
salariés dans un établissement
médico-social et présent depuis près de
10 ans sur le sol français un désarroi
généralisé dans beaucoup de secteurs en
tension qui n'arrivent plus à recruter
malgré une revalorisation des salaires
du mal à recruter d'un côté du à
conserver les salariés de l'autre le
Républicain Lorrain metat à ça une ce
cri d'alarme des enseignants à bout de
souffle en Lorraine comme partout
d'ailleurs face à la dégradation de
leurs conditions de travail on voit de
plus en plus enseignants d'émissionné
Marie 19 ans d'enseignement Valérie 26
ans dans l'éducation nationale et Sophie
une dizaine d'années en tant que
professeurs trois histoires qui se
rejoignent sur la conclusion d'un
système éducatif à bout et qui aussi
bien physiquement que nerveusement ses
principaux acteurs
du foot l'OM connaît enfin son nouvel
entraîneur après le départ largement
commenté de l'espagnol Marcelino c'est
un Jena rogatuso connu pour son
caractère et ses coups d'éclats qui
débarquent sur le bande Olympia le
journal La Marseillaise annonce que le
rhinocéros milanais arrive à la
rescousse de l'OM la Provence déroule
dans ses pages les dessous d'une arrivée
surprise ça promet
je regarde vos il a une des échos les
paris du budget 2024 tout à fait on
apprend on découvre la stratégie
détaillée avec moult graphique de la
stratégie du gouvernement pour faire
pour lutter contre l'inflation
c'est-à-dire dans les écoles de
politique cette semaine pierre c'est un
appel des victimes et des familles
Emmanuel Macron oui 3 mois après la mort
de Naëlle tu es par la police après un
refus ou en tout cas un
présomption de refus d'obtempérer on
revient sur sur ce qu'on appelle les
violences policières et effectivement il
y a une trentaine de familles et
victimes de violences policières qui
s'exprime dans nos pages pour s'adresser
aux présidents de la République et lui
faire un certain nombre de propositions
j'insiste aussi sur une autre chose dans
le numéro de cette semaine c'est un
entretien passionnant avec Achille MB
qui a un intellectuel camerounais qui
revient sur les coups d'État en ce
moment en Afrique et les liens que lui
estime à reconstruire entre la France et
l'Afrique et tout ça c'est-à-dire cette
semaine dans politique merci beaucoup
Serge lac main d'être venu merci Jacques
Pogam de Johnny également merci Mathias
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis pour
voir où voir cette émission c'est sur
public sena.fr à 18h vous avez
rendez-vous avec Thomas et pour son
public et nous on se retrouve demain
très bonne journée
que la presse quotidienne régionale et
les télévisions locales vous ont
présenté le club des territoires
[Musique]